[Music]  ted we'll see in a few minutes the eight  news now i-team learning brand new  information about one of two people  arrested in las vegas in connection to  the riot at the u.s capitol brian a  search of court records led us to  discover one of those arrested is  nathaniel j  degray of a government search led them  to an apartment here in las vegas  now the criminal complaint against  degree filed in u.s district court  says he violated the following codes  knowingly entering or remaining in any  restricted buildings or grounds without  lawful authority violent entry and  disorderly conduct on capitol grounds  and obstruction of law enforcement  during civil disorder  now the i-team is working to gather  information on the other person arrested  hundreds of trump supporters stormed the  riot  and created the riot earlier this month  and five people died  again the 8 news now i-team will have  more on this coming up tomorrow